mehr als 30 jahre nach seiner ersten
bewerbung für die
präsidentschaftskandidatur charakter
steht zur wahl mitgefühl steht zur wahl
anstand wissenschaft demokratie jetzt
der dritte versuch ins weiße haus
einzuziehen
hier und jetzt gebe ich mein wort wenn
ihr mir das präsidentenamt anvertraut
hole ich das beste aus uns raus nicht
das schlechteste
er will die führung eines landes
übernehmen das tief in einer corona der
wirtschafts und rassismus krise steckt
und er will eine nation befrieden die
wohl gespaltener ist als je zuvor
worüber wähler im moment gerade
diskutieren ist er besser als chance
jetzt muss joe biden vor allem zeigen
wer nicht ist
er ist nicht der job nach 50 jahren in
der politik nach schweren persönlichen
schicksalsschlägen ist er nun die
demokratische antwort auf einen
präsidenten der wie kaum ein anderer
polarisiert
biden hatte immer mitgefühl für andere
und das ist etwas das seine karriere
definiert hat doch sollte joe biden
gewinnen wäre er mit 78 jahren bei
amtseinführung der älteste präsident in
der geschichte der vereinigten staaten
trauen ihm die amerikaner zu es besser
zu machen als der amtsinhaber und das
land in eine bessere zukunft zu führen
märz 2020 super tuesday
in gleich 14 bundesstaaten finden an
diesem dienstag demokratischen vorwahlen
statt es wird der tag des geweihten nur
noch ein weiterer ernst zu nehmender
konkurrent im rennen beiden schlägt den
linksgerichteten senator bernie sanders
deutlich wir sind sehr lebendig unsere
kampagne spiegelt die vielfalt ihres
landes wieder so muss es sein denn wir
müssen jetzt jeden mitnehmen jeden dabei
hatten viele beiden direkt zu beginn des
vorbei marathon schon für politisch tot
erklärt als spitzenkandidat schafft er
es bei der ersten vorwahl in iowa nur
auf platz vier
bei der zweiten in new hampshire sogar
nur auf platz fünf ein katastrophaler
start bei auftritten vor wählern und
während debatten mit der
innerparteilichen konkurrenz wirkt er
teilweise müde und abgekämpft
[Musik]
der grund für seinen schweren start ist
dass er die letzten vier jahre keine
politik gemacht hat nachdem sein amt
endete hat er einen ganz anderen alltag
als vorher
und plötzlich fast vier jahre später als
kandidat wieder in den rhythmus zu
kommen
man kann das nicht einfach an oder
ausschalten und dennoch ist er es leben
die demokraten am ehesten zutrauen
donald trump zu schlafen
die partei den linksruck setzt mit dem
polit veteranen beiden auf altbewährtes
und schickt mit ihm einen mann der mitte
in eine historische wahlschlacht der
jetzige präsident hat amerika viel zu
lange in dunkelheit gehüllt zu viel wut
zu viel angst zu viel spaltung beiden
gibt sich als versöhner als verstehe und
so durchschnittlich wie die amerikaner
ihn seit jahrzehnten kennen
in der ehemaligen industriestadt quentin
pennsylvania wird beiden 1942 in
bescheidene familienverhältnisse geboren
erst als die eltern nach wilmink
delaware umziehen findet der vater eine
dauerhafte arbeit
ihrem ältesten sohn joe und den
geschwistern bringen sie zusammenhalt
und durchhaltevermögen bei als beiden
seien jahrelang heftiges stottern und
den dazugehörigen spott von mitschülern
leid ist trainiert er sich den sprech
fehler mit hilfe von gedichten selbst ab
beiden ist ein fleißiger aber
durchschnittlicher student er arbeitet
im sommer im schwimmbad eines vor allem
von schwarzen bewohnten viertels in
wilmington er will kontakte in die black
community knüpfen
noch vor seinem juraabschluss heiratet
beiden seine große liebe meliá hunter
den jungen familienvater zieht es in die
politik
er ist erst 29 jahre alt als er für den
us senat in washington kandidiert und
gewinnt das war ein typ der präsident
werden wollte sobald er in den senat kam
überambitioniert für jemanden mit seiner
herkunft aber er war durstig danach
doch bevor der neue junge star der
demokraten tatsächlich nach washington
um zieht der erste schwere
schicksalsschlag meliá beiden und die
gemeinsame tochter sterben bei einem
autounfall
die beiden söhne werden verletzt beide
überlegt seine politische karriere zu
beenden und schwört dann im krankenhaus
doch den eid auf die verfassung
da war dieser junge mann
die leute nicht kannten er war vorher
noch nicht einmal in der landespolitik
gewesen aber durch diesen ersten
schicksalsschlag in seinem leben ist die
ganze nation auf ihn aufmerksam geworden
er hatte immer mitgefühl für andere und
das ist etwas das seine karriere
definiert als beiden vizepräsident ist
wird bei seinem ältesten sohn wo ein
bösartiger gehirntumor diagnostiziert
2015 stirbt auch er
beides biografie ist eine öffentliche
leidensgeschichte die er nun in seiner
wahlkampf kampagne für sich nutzt ich
höre euch fühlen mit euch ist seine
botschaft als krasser gegenpol zu donald
bren wie geht's dir wenn sie präsident
werden sorgen sie dafür dass wir gute
landesweite und lokale gesetze bekommen
vor allem wenn es um polizeigewalt geht
wenn tram poltert gibt sich beiden
seriöse und präsidial
wenn trump nach canossa fliegt um nach
teils gewaltsamen antirassismus
protesten den harten sheriff zu geben
bietet beiden dort mit der schwarzen
gemeinde wenn zeugen den medienberichten
wie trump gefallene soldaten als
verlierer und trottel bezeichnete und
der präsident selbst auf
tonbandaufnahmen zugibt die gefahr des
corona virus öffentlich heruntergespielt
zu haben
dann tritt beiden auf als das moralische
gewissen des landes
mein sohn ist als freiwilliger mit der
us-armee in den ihrer gegangen er war
kein trottel die mit denen er gedient
hat vor allem die die nicht zurückkamen
waren keine verlierer
er wusste um die gefahr
und als die tödliche krankheit in
relation zerriss hat er seinen job mit
absicht nicht gemacht
joe biden der anti trump mit einer
kampagne die er zu beginn der korona
krise über monate hinweg nur aus seinem
privat keller führte der moderator
demokrat erklärt langeweile zum
wahlkampf prinzip ruhige wohldosierte
auftritte weniger aussagen bleiben
hängen es geht vor allem um die eine
botschaft ich bin nicht donald shop bei
dieser wahl geht es um tram richtung
beiden es kommt selten vor dass ein
amtierender präsident aus dem amt
geworfen wird kastriert ist es schon
aber eben nur wenige male doch jedes mal
wenn es dazu kam war die person die
gewann auf eine ganz besondere art und
weise
das genaue gegenteil des vorherigen
amtsinhabers
die korona krise erlaubt joe biden einen
wahlkampf auf sparflamme
die meisten auftritte per livestream
wenn er unterwegs ist wird nur ein
kleiner presse pool zu belassen
so kann beiden auch eine seiner größten
schwächen verstecken seien bereits
legendäres talent für patzer und
versprecher wir stellen die wahrheit
über fakten arme kinder sind so schlau
und talentiert wie weiße kinder männer
und frauen sind der tram kampagne gibt
der demokrat mit seinen aussetzern jede
menge munition beinahe mantraartig
versucht sie in wahlwerbespot beiden zu
unterstellen mit 77 jahren nicht mehr
ganz auf der höhe zu sein
lasst uns die schlafmütze juwelen der
sagt immer die namen falsch ich sehe ihn
nicht als gefahr erst nur eine gefahr
für sich selbst
wer den in einer debatte nicht schlägt
hatten ernstes problem
trump will damit übertönen das ihn mit
joe biden ein erfahrener
vollblutpolitiker gegenübersteht
einer der in seinen 36 jahren als us
senator unzählige kompromisse mit den
republikanern beschlossen hat der als
guter vermittler gilt mit verbündeten in
beiden lagern als vizepräsident unter
barack obama etwa verhandelt er die
gesundheitsreform obamacare maßgeblich
mit
zum ende seiner amtszeit gibt es vom
chef mit der freiheitsmedaille die
höchste zivile auszeichnung der usa
aber in seiner langen politkarriere
steht beiden auch nicht immer auf der
richtigen seite der geschichte
als die afro amerikanerin anita heer
1991 dem kandidatin für den obersten
gerichtshof sexuelle belästigung
vorwirft sorgt beiden als vorsitzender
des justizausschusses nicht für eine
faire anhörung 1994 schreibt er an der
kreml mit ein gesetz das schon minder
schwere straftaten hart bestraft und vor
allem junge schwarze männer hinter
gitter bringt 2002 stimmt er für den
irakkrieg der zum außenpolitischen
desaster wird während der jetzigen
vorwahlen hat beiden eine menge contra
von den eigenen leuten bekommen und das
lag auch an der crime will die joe biden
als vorsitzender des justizausschusses
durch den senat gebracht hat
damit haben wir die polizei
militarisiert und es stellt sich raus
das war keine gute idee die inhaftierung
rate von afro amerikanern und anderen
menschen of color in unseren
gefängnissen ist massiv gestiegen dieses
gesetz ist zum großen teil dafür
verantwortlich
und doch verspricht die beiden nun der
heiler für ein land zu sein dessen
polizei gewalt vor allem gegen schwarze
die massen auf die straße treibt er
verspricht durch ein besseres management
in der korona krise mehr menschenleben
zu retten die am boden liegende
wirtschaft aufzubauen
und er verspricht eine tief gespaltene
gesellschaft wieder zu fahren
dabei setzt er vor allem darauf den
status quo vor der ära tram
wiederherstellen zu wollen
rückkehr zur normalität ohne große
politische visionen für die zukunft
euphorie löst er damit im ganzen land
nicht aus aber möglicherweise reicht es
schon wenn joe biden nur oft genug
betont dass er nicht damit schon ist
[Musik]